I guess I'm the only one doing this
holiday right hitting the open road with
my bike no family no friends no dinner
that sounds really dark
thank you what'd you do undercover I
worked for Jimmy The Butcher figures
that is an A-list mobster tell me
literally everything everyone shut up
pretty much just a Bag Man for him
I mean I did some other stuff
[Music]
we usually try to tell funnier little
stories well there's nothing funny about
what I did for the butcher I've had to
learn not to Blink because every time I
close my eyes I see a fresh Horror oh
dark how do you keep your eyes moist no
actually I have a very funny story about
keeping my eyes moist
nope still not getting that Vibe man
really
you forgot your lunch at home oh thanks
Adrian it's sweetest of course I french
kissed every slice of meat in that
sandwich pimento welcome back how
it was kind of boring actually although
one funny thing did happen to me
foreign
idea about what a funny thing is
[Music]
good morning Caleb oh you woke up happy
for once you're damn right I did
it's visiting day
happy visiting day happy visiting day
Tommy excited for the family to come
Tino is Marie on her way Miguel happy
visiting to Andy hung himself
oh my God guard can't believe what
you've done no you're flustered you have
no GPS so you just start driving no next
thing you know you're in the Pine
Barrens and it hits you your uncle's
cabin he has a place there you're the
luckiest son yes it was you got lucky at
every turn no I knew exactly where I was
driving I left my phone in the office on
purpose I was in a surgical Suite by
Design and I didn't use some glass award
that any idiot would clearly see was
missing I made a rod out of a special
dental polymer killed him with it then
melted it back down it's already in a
patient's mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh damn and that is
three oh damn
oh damn what's this I hear about you
being on administrative leave a year ago
my wife and I had twin baby girls
Cagney and Lacey they have adorable
chubby cheeks ever since I kind of got
scared of getting hurt lost my Edge
there was an incident in a department
store
hey man you okay you look a little
chubby I'm fine I'm fine
oh
I think he's dead put that gun down or
he dies he's not gonna shoot me he needs
me alive to get out of here yeah you
willing to take that bet I wouldn't
now Put the gun down
oh you shot him oh God are you okay I'm
sorry I shot you I thought that's what
the nod meant it was it was awesome it
was actually just like the end of speed
which is a pretty good movie it's not as
good as I heard tires for Vegas yeah I
was gonna say you should keep going
after fingers same page still hey do you
happen to know my blood type yeah be
positive well guess wrong hey Craig the
butcher says he has Spies of the NYPD so
I trust none of these dildos listen you
can trust me I'm like obsessed with you
okay fine tell me something you've never
told another living soul
um oh here's one I'm actually not strong
enough to lift a water cooler jug so I
always find a way to make Terry do it
here's mine Jimmy The Butcher made me
drive a croquet Wicket through a guy's
eyes into his brain
leaked out his eyes like he was crying
his own mind my goodness
now that I've heard yours I feel like my
water cooler thing could have been a
little more juicy but in protective
custody because everyone in gem pop
hates cops I'm not really sure why
something about us locking them in cages
and letting the world pass them by I
can't believe I'm about to say this but
Bill
tell us all about yourself let's start
with my whole family history I was
abandoned at a playground as an infant
and here I am
oh that was the whole thing the
infinitude gems will go back to Bill
whose life seems to have unraveled even
further tough March for you there bud
yeah just a heads up I sold my pants
with the pocket so I'll be putting the
gems in my undies this time no I'll give
him a fanny pack can I keep it this
could be just what I need to turn my
life around yeah belt you can keep the
baby I don't have to do anything for it
do I because I will if you ask I'll do
anything even
how'd you get in the apartment oh it was
easy I just seduced the old lady
upstairs came down the fire escape Jimmy
the window open Bing Bang Boom I'm
inside your living quarters totally
of course next time you could just give
me a call you know two ways to pop in on
a friend I didn't kill the old lady
upstairs if that's what you're worried
about well I am now how can I ever thank
you sorry
tell yourself again
just those gross overly large muscles
lay off my body dude I clearly got some
stuff to work through
save that Amy do not make me taste you
again
what I just turned out it's a girl oh my
God oh my God it's happening quick
someone get a reaction video of me
becoming an uncle ah she's making it up
the pregnancy scan was my idea no no no
no no Amy wait is that true did you just
lie to me about our baby did you lie to
us about her baby
first she's a grown-up who made her own
decisions and now she has to suffer the
consequences you might not get it but
personally I relate to someone who made
a mistake and can't find their way out
of it when I was younger I was
thoroughly Hoodwinked by the so-called
Good People at Columbia CD Club next
thing you know I had 16 copies of blind
melon's first album in high school I
broke into a bunch of houses and wound
up and juvie what that's terrible I mean
yeah roses is a little worse the alarm
went off before we could even talk oh
that's too bad brother but at least you
have people that want to come and visit
you my family hasn't been to see me
since my trial you eat nine people and
all of a sudden they don't know who you
are anymore great
what
did you say eat people
cannibal Caleb well that's not how I
would Define myself if we're going by
what I'm most passionate about I would
say that I'm a woodworker why did you
think I was in protective custody I
don't know I guess I hoped you were
another cop wrongly convicted of crimes
you didn't commit nope I did all my
stuff and more there's tons they can't
even Trace to me the secret is eating
the evidence okay
yeah herb knew where the camera was must
have case The Joint ahead of time we're
gonna need all your footage from the
past week
this is an amateur job everybody knows
you break in when the owner's there that
way you have guaranteed access to the
safe and you can kick his teeth in to
send a message okay why don't you just
oh sure you can slit this through it but
then what are you gonna do with all the
blood okay
no big deal five days is nothing I'm not
afraid to be alone with my thoughts my
thoughts are awesome die hard sex on a
cruise ship pizza bagel restaurant my
father never loved me and I'm gonna die
alone oh boy that happened fast guard
that was your first dent in Solitaire it
was nothing I held it together oh
Amy when did you get here you've come
for my conjugal capabilities
you're lucky I'm not a real good girl
hosta booby no matter I'll just build
another one more mashed potatoes
Jake it's so good to see you come give
me a hug I'm not gonna eat you also
don't hug me because I will try to eat
you
this is such a surprise I haven't seen
you since I transferred here how's Amy
she's great we're married and she's a
sergeant now wow yeah how's everything
here yeah same old same oh guess who's
here Herman Herman always playing
Yahtzee knew everybody's name worship
Satan did he he never mentioned that
shut up about is exhausting well I'm
Charles I'm Jake's best friend Charles
he's serving three life sentences no
need to flex so Caleb we're tracking a
serial killer and I was thinking you
could help us get inside his head just
because I ate humans doesn't mean that
I'm inhuman Jake Caleb come on that's
not what I meant I'm just kidding I'm
probably friends with a guy online
what's his deal well he's been murdering
young men and cutting out their hearts
ooh what I would never eat out hard I
stick to the normal stuff butts and
thighs one time I ate a foot but it was
nasty yeah I could see that you know
what there was some weird guy on the
Forum recently before him yeah it's a
chat room for people who like to talk
about eating human beings but definitely
won't act on it wink yeah it's hosted on
Reddit obviously anyways he showed up
from out of nowhere asking questions
about cutting out Hearts really do you
know anything else about him I've never
seen him on there before but you could
check the logs I'll approve you I'm an
admin oh you might want to switch to
incognito mode otherwise your targeted
ads will be pretty cannibal specific ah
good to know well it was good to see you
Caleb send me that info
okay